sorry Media it looks like Iran hates its
own government more than it hates us
instead of burning u.s. flags what did
you see at Sunday's protests in Iran
over its government shooting down that
airliner a bunch of Iranians refusing to
act the way our media wish they would
demonstrators refused to walk on
American and Israeli flags while others
attacked images of general Soleimani yes
as much as they were expected to despise
those two countries it seems they load
the Revolutionary Guard much more video
also showed government forces firing
live ammo at the protesters media
outrage here seems at a low ebb though
there's still too busy complaining about
Trump tweeting mean things about them
yeah and Iran people who speak out
endure bullets yet in America the
outrage is over memes but also the
Oscars
what no Best Director for little women
poor Greta
I blame Trump meanwhile yet another
media narrative implodes we now learn
that Trump authorized the killing of
salamati seven months ago talked about
impulsive erratic unstable Trump only
waited 7 months to take the guy out
clearly he's a maniac crazy on bloodlust
where's the 24th amendment when you need
it so once again the media lies to you
about everything
they painted soleimani as a folk hero
not true and they repeat the lie that
Trump was acting irrationally part of
the Mad Men persona they helped
fabricate it's not true either only in
America can our media get everything so
wrong and still see themselves as the
good guys I guess that's the only way
they can look in the mirror without
throwing up
welcome back Dana from your quote
Dennett tennis camp unquote that's what
we're calling it
tennis camp who goes to tennis camp
America so you wouldn't believe what I
really did can't wait to hear about it
in the break so does this feel like a
new chapter in Iran or is that wishful
thinking on my part I think it might be
possibly know though we've seen this
story and it because it writes itself
over and over again so I believe that
everybody in every human being is born
with this desire for freedom it's innate
it's something that we all have so then
you have these dictatorial governments
that are trying to ram down people's
throats to keep them down keep them from
opportunity
tell them what to wear tell them what to
think they were they want their talents
and they want their brains but they
don't respect their hearts and so you
see this in Hong Kong yeah Venezuela
mm-hmm
Iraq Lebanon now Iran Manhattan think
about the ha ha ha go get to that um you
think about the Arab Spring yeah so
there are these movements and then they
get snuffed out and you think up
Venezuela for example like so we kind of
help but then we can't do it all right
so I do think it's a possibility that
there could be some changes but that
would mean that Iran would have to
change quite fundamentally and I would
bet that they're biding their time right
now but what we know about them in
December 'iron killed about 900 of its
own citizens in because they were
protesting and this is before any of
this happened yeah but maybe that might
have been directed by Soleimani who is
no longer here Jesse yeah it was yes
thank you for that Jesse I get the
feeling that maybe Iran wasn't as
overjoyed or in love with Sal Imani as
our media told us yeah I bet the people
that came out to mourn Soleimani were
people that were backed by the Iranian
regime and it's funny that the media is
taking the same perspective as the
Iranian regime think about it they
mourned Soleimani both of us and then
they blamed Trump for shooting down the
airline both the American media and the
Iranian regime and then they said that
the street protests oh no those street
protests there's lots of reasons for
people to be on the street maybe
somewhere shopping maybe they were just
out getting a breath of fresh air but
that fundamentally misunderstands the
threat of protesting in Iran you can get
put to death if you chant death to
Ayatollah which they were doing it
doesn't take any bravery to chant death
to Trump down with America it's an evil
empire everybody does that over there
and they're doing that because they get
paid to do it
now when Trump goes in there and takes
out a bad guy without having to pay a
bribe with no American casualties 9 out
of 10 Americans give the guy a round of
applause only the media creates a
scandal over Trump killing a terrorist
how many terrorists did Barack Obama
take out in the Taliban
how many generals in Libya across the
Middle East he didn't have his guys go
on the sunday shows the next weekend
telling the media oh here is the
documentary evidence that he had that he
was planning an imminent attack he
didn't have to do that because the media
didn't demand he'd do that Solomon is in
business to kill Americans his job for
the last three decades is the plot
attack against Americans and our allies
we don't need a specific piece of raw
intelligence saying oh he's about to
kill an American so he does for a living
so he killed him first and there's
nothing scandalous about that at all Wan
feel free to respond to anything this
brilliant man just said I don't know
where to start with go after and kill
terrorists I mean in so many drones that
were so unconcerned about wait his use
of drones to kill terrorists that people
said why is he doing this and why
doesn't it what if we're gonna go in
should we send troops as opposed anyway
let me just go listen he was not
hammered away this is crazy when Barack
Obama's app is not right but okay let me
Greg when you Greg you are conflating
two very separate events after Soleimani
x' assassination killing whatever you
want to call it there were people in the
streets Jesse says they were paid I
don't know you're in the street that's
what you guys say but I just know now
there are people in the streets
legitimately much as I think Americans
would be upset if our government shot
down an airline but they're not the two
of the same events there's separate
events and they have every reason to be
angry at their government which is now
admitted that they made a huge mistake
that took a hundred plus lives I don't
think I wasn't complaining
okay I think you were saying oh they're
in the streets now they're sweet they
must are saying they hate
their government we're not they hate
Trump that's not true that's true and
you go in Iran no here's that here's the
other part of this the idea that somehow
Democrats are to be as Trump was today
putting Schumer and Pelosi in this
picture with the Arab here domain yeah
and they're at the Iranian related to me
this is a vile thing that somehow Viola
Kratz
don't go after terrorists or hate on
people like Sola money every Democrat
has made a clear statement so money was
a bad guy and then finally that NBC then
says oh yes seven months ago he gave the
authorization if you have a shot okay so
then Trump comes out and says what
difference does it make if if I had
information about an imminent attack the
Defense Secretary says I never saw any
evidence of any imminent attack Trump
says the Lord Ingram oh there were four
embassy this guy's making stuff up if
you guys are just running around like Oh
anything he does is just fine number one
we do realize you're only allowed to say
imminent when you're talking about
climate change right that's the only
Democrats can use the word imminent and
as to do with global warming okay Emily
I want to get you in here I honestly
think that what we're seeing right now
is the real Iran and it's a knob but the
door is opening for actually some new
dialogue that had been blocked
obstructed by the guy who's now dead
salamati yes I agree and I want to speak
to just the perspective of the left and
the mainstream media on these protests
because the protest became inconvenient
for the left and inconvenient for our
media because up until then the Iranians
were used as a tool for both of those
entities when it was an anti-trump
vehicle for them they were able to
further that message and these are
people allegedly who care deeply about
democracy and freedom and those tenants
and yet all of a sudden they are mute
when as you said not two months ago up
to fifteen hundred citizens were
murdered for protesting increase in gas
prices these protesters are out there
literally risking their lives because
they are saying death to the supreme
leader and they are saying specifically
Trump is not the problem
soleimani is the Iranian or was the
Iranian government is they are literally
blowing
open the sham and the bullying to let
that light in and there have been
crickets from both the left and the
mainstream media final point this the
foreign threat and the regime and the
terror state that Iran is that is a
bipartisan threat and the most dangerous
thing we can all do to ourselves because
believe me we all bleed the same is to
politicize this so I really hope that
the left gets in gear and starts viewing
this from an American perspective rather
than an anti-trump perspective alright